this is the CCTV video which has shocked
Mexico inside a migrant Detention Center
a Mexican official and security guard
walked by just as flames take hold
inside the cell of migrants locked up
under their care
it was Ablaze this Monday night which
ultimately killed dozens of people the
majority of them Guatemalans they've
been detained and held in ciard Juarez
right at Mexico's border with the United
States
president Andres Manuel Lopez obrador
had said on Tuesday that they themselves
had started the fire in protest at their
upcoming deportation but on Wednesday
with the video coming to light he was
forced to confront allegations that his
own government's officials appear guilty
of the worst kind of negligence letting
people die he
gay
thinking there will be no impunity those
responsible for this painful tragedy
will be identified they will be held
accountable and punished in accordance
with the law
later in the day the Mexican Attorney
General's office requested arrest
warrants for several people in
connection with the fire
in ciudad Juarez morning
and as the names of the Dead were read
out calls for justice
it has the right to be safe to be
protected not to be mistreated or
violated by any Authority because we are
not criminals
there have been tensions within the
Border City for weeks caused by the
large number of migrants and Asylum
Seekers gathered there some launching
chaotic pushes to try to get into the
U.S disrupting local Commerce
while authorities have been accused of
using heavy-handed tactics to round them
up and get them out
but this isn't just an issue for Juarez
there are detention centers for migrants
across the country
small protests here outside of Mexico's
interior Ministry but this has been an
issue for some time in the country
migrant detention centers which migrants
themselves and activists have described
as little better than overcrowded
prisons
the reality is that Mexico's
relationship with the United States
depends in part on its stopping migrants
from getting through and to its powerful
Northern neighbor
so the detention centers and
deportations will remain
but tragedies like this one raise yet
more red flags about the attitude and
treatment towards the migrants held
within them
John Holman Al Jazeera Mexico City